(audience applauds) (mellow music)
(Evangeline laughs)
- You walked out, and I was like,
it was like Madonna's
song "Vogue" was playing.
You look so cool.
♪ It's all for you ♪
- Okay, I like, nice song. Yeah.
♪ Say you really want it ♪
- That's a great song.
All right, so you have two
boys, eleven and seven.
Oh, that's a lot of boys in the house.
I only have one, and that's a lot.
So, you grew up with women though, right?
- [Evangeline] Yeah.
- Just sisters.
- Just sisters and just
female cousins, as well.
It's just a world of estrogen.
- [Kelly] Whoa.
- Yeah.
- God was just placing
a challenge before you.
Yeah, with the two boys.
- Well, I don't know why I always knew
I was gonna have boys.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah?
- Yeah, because I couldn't
deal with girls' drama ever.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Never, not even when I
was a young teenage girl.
- I know a couple guys
that are just chickens.
They're hens. Yeah, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, you've made a very
good point there, Kelly.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I was
like, "I know a lot of guys
that are hens that like to stir a pot."
I don't know if this is true.
(Kelly chuckling)
- But I have to say, even as a girl,
I thought that boys at this
age, like eleven and seven,
especially eleven, middle
school, were so weird.
I couldn't understand
them for the life of me.
And as a mom now-
- They're just simple.
- Strange though, strange.
- Yeah.
- And as a mom now, I'm like,
I still don't understand.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't know what's going on here,
I don't understand the noises
coming out of your mouth.
(audience laughing)
- My son is Max, from Wild
Things. He's that character.
- [Evangeline] My oldest
son is like that as well.
Yeah. And he has this,
he makes up weird sayings
and sounds, and he just
says them over and over.
He's got this one where he goes,
he says to his younger brother,
"I'm sorry for touching your bum bum".
- [Kelly] That's it, no.
(audience laughs)
Why do they love saying, they love...
My son is just like "Poop".
(Everyone laughing)
And I'm like, "Yep, okay."
It's like, they get,
he just loves weird words like that.
- Yeah.
- And you're like, it's not really funny,
but I'll laugh with you.
- For your sake.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Again, I'm having flashbacks.
- I'm teaching you what the
girl's gonna do on the date,
to pretend you're funny.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Exactly.
- It's like, Anyway, my son is six,
so what do I have to look forward to?
He's already a little
strange, in an awesome way.
- Always an awesome way.
- I haven't gotten into boy B.O yet.
- [Evangeline] Yeah.
- Have you gotten into that?
- No. Just a little
tiny touch, not so much.
Although, the girls his age
aren't smelling so good,
I've gotta tell you.
- Yeah. Well, that happens.
- They've gone there.
- Yeah.
- But you do have to look forward to him
thinking you are not cool
and being your worst critic.
So, that is definitely on the way.
- That's already happening.
- Well, well done. Well done, you.
(everyone laughing)
- He is advanced.
- Yes, exactly. Yeah.
- Sometimes, every once in a while,
I'll do something really
cool, or if I know someone.
- [Evangeline] Uh-huh.
I've met Owen from Jurassic
World, and he's like-
- [Evangeline] Oh.
- Yeah, that's his favorite person.
- [Evangeline] You're in now.
- Yeah.
- I thought I might be in
once I became an Avenger-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Evangeline] And then my son, of course-
- [Kelly] How did you not, with that?
- Well, he can always find
the way that I am not cool.
- I'm like, these are high standards.
- I know. He was like,
"Mom, why do you have to
be the worst Avenger?"
(audience gasping) (Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
"Why couldn't you be Iron Man?"
And I was like, Okay.
- Well.
- I'm trying my very
best. Well, there's a...
- Not a man.
- Yeah, that helps.
But then, now with Quantumania,
I've sort of, graduated
to being a senior Avenger.
And he's like, "Okay
mom, now you're cool."
- Yeah. I'm like, oh my
God, that would be like...
How was the costume for you?
Because I always feel like,
when y'all wear all those
costumes, I hear everybody talk
about how uncomfortable
they are. Was yours?
- Yeah, no. I love, I mean...
- [Kelly] You loved it?
- [Evangeline] I took naps in my costume.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] I've gotta be honest with you,
if I looked like that in that costume,
I'd probably keep it on too.
- (Evangeline chuckling)
You'd nap in it also. Yeah.
- I would walk into Target like that.
- I don't, honestly, I've said it before,
but I think the reason why people complain
about their costumes is
because the "people" are mostly
male "people." And they're not
used to suffering for beauty.
They're not used to being, you know-
- Spanx. They're not used to all that.
- Like corseted into a gown.
- Yeah.
- We're like-
- Welcome to the dark side fellas.
(everyone laughing)
Yeah, it's uncomfortable.
- Welcome to leather and corsets.
- Yeah, try birth. Okay.
(audience applauding)
- So you live in Hawaii
now, and I have to ask,
this was the most beautiful
footage I've ever seen.
Do butterflies just land
on people all the time?
Look at this footage.
That's a real butterfly just
hanging out on her head!
(Evangeline laughing)
And you're so peaceful and zen about it.
In the video there's music
playing and it's like-
- Can I tell you how much that tickled?
(audience laughing)
That was-
- [Kelly] How do you not wipe it away.
- I could feel the little
feet grabbing my eyelids,
and plucking away at them,
but it was just too cool of an
opportunity not to stay still
and let it cruise.
- [Kelly] It's so cool.
- It happens all of the time.
I mean, everyone in Hawaii has butterflies
in their face all the time.
(audience laughing)
- That's not true.
- No, it's totally true.
- (chuckling) It's not.
- Life out there is Snow
White and the seven dwarves.
- Are you serious?
- Well, except I only have
two doors and a husband.
- [Kelly] Yes. Yes.
(audience laughing)
- But, same idea.
- [Kelly] You're working on it.
I just thought that was so peaceful.
Again, I was like, you have found balance-
(Evangeline laughing)
when that can happen in your life.
But also when you were younger,
you were a flight attendant.
So how did, I didn't know
that. So how did that...
How were people? I feel like
that's one of the worst jobs.
People, you get people in grumpy spaces.
- Well, you gotta remember
this was 25 years ago.
- Oh my gosh.
- (chuckling) People were
so much nicer 25 years ago.
- That is totally true.
- People are miserable now.
- Okay.
- [Evangeline] Yeah, they're miserable.
- Maybe they were faking
it back then, though.
- Well, yeah.
- Maybe they're just
honest now. (chuckling)
- But you know, every once in
a while there would be that
flyer that was miserable and mean,
and unkind and deserving
of some sort of punishment.
And so the real only punishment
I had at my disposal was
a little flyby crop dusting.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
just a little boop, just a little boop.
And then just keep going.
And they'd be like, "Oh,
who did that to me?"
- (chuckling) Crop
dusting. That's a good one.
And I'd be like, "Not me. What?"
- [Kelly] What?
- "Not me."
- [Kelly] Not little old me.
- "I'm just a fly attendant."
- You're just tooting.
(everyone laughing)
- Past the grumpy guy,
which is probably making
him even more grump, which
is winning. You're winning.
- Which is so winning.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- And I love that you said "tooting."
- [Kelly] Tooting. I know.
I just love that you were
crop dusting passengers.
We would've been friends.
- We totally are now.
- [Kelly] That is already funny.
So wait, we were talking
about your kids before,
and you have this kids
book. This is awesome.
- I do.
What can you tell us about them?
What made you wanna do
this? This is awesome.
- Well, I was a little
kid who hated reading,
because the books were always
too long and too wordy.
And I was a very slow reader.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But then the ones that
were short and sweet
and had great illustrations
were just kiddie stuff,
and they were boring and they
weren't sophisticated enough.
- Yeah.
- So I was like, I'm gonna make the book
that I would've wanted
to read when I was a kid.
- That's the smartest thing to
do, something you would want.
Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. And then I call
them cautionary tales
for modern day brats, because-
(everyone laughing)
Because our kids have become brats,
cause we don't tell these
stories to them anymore.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Which are like, just so you know-
- [Kelly] Like warnings.
- If you're a jerk, your
life might not go so well.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's just reality.
- You could die like the evil queen.
- [Evangeline] Yeah, exactly.
- You could get put in an
oven like the evil witch.
- Yeah, exactly.
- You might get burned-
- [Kelly] Let's scar them. (chuckling)
- Yes. Those are important things to do.
- Fairy tales are scary, but they do have
amazing life lessons.
- And I call them for modern day brats,
cause they're not that same shaming thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They're just like,
they're gently cautionary.
And there's always, in the
end, a redemptive story,
which is essentially like
in our worst failures
is when we can wake up
and realize how to do better next time.
- [Kelly] Yeah. Absolutely.
- Yeah.
- And teaching them that
failure is a reality.
- Yeah.
- We're not always gonna win.
- And for those parents
who are too afraid to
actually let their children really lose,
which is clearly not us-
- [Kelly] You're hurting them. Yeah.
Clearly. (chuckling)
- Clearly. This is a really
safe place to do that.
Right.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- Stories are a safe
place for a kid to learn
about losing and to learn about
mistakes and to learn that
all my protagonists
are desperately flawed.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know, the conversation
is like, "Mommy's flawed,
you're flawed, we're all gonna screw up.
So how do we deal with it?"
Not like, "Let's protect
you from ever screwing up."
That's not healthy.
- [Kelly] I know.
- That's not helpful.
- Yeah, I agree.
- Yeah, we love each other.
This is what's happening now.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We're the same person, I think.
- Did we just become BFF's?
- I think we did. I think that
just happened on this show.
- [Kelly] What movie is
that? Is that Step Brothers?
(Evangeline chuckling)
"Did we just become best friends?"
(audience laughing)
So wait, we need to talk
about Quantumania, because
I'm super stoked. I'm a Marvel like freak.
(audience cheering)
So where do we find Hope,
Aka the Wasp, where do
we find you in this?
- So-
- Because the trailer's so good.
- Oh good. Yeah, I know
the trailers are so good.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I'm very excited.
- It even got me.
- Yeah, you're like, where are they going?
- Yeah.
- They get sucked in, yeah.
- And I've made the movie!
- I'm very excited. Yes.
- Yeah, well in the first film,
Hope was like permanent
resting bitch face. Right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That was her-
- It's just fun to play.
- Yeah, really fun to play.
But now she's like Perma-smile.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- She's like-
- [Kelly] She's selling
Girl Scout cookies. Yeah.
- Yeah. She's fixed her
relationship with her dad,
she's reunited with her mom,
she's falling in love with Scott,
she's step-momming
Cassie. Life is perfect.
She's in a really good place.
- Okay.
- And she's spreading all that love
to the world through her
humanitarian work and-
- Yeah.
- Yeah, like things can't
go wrong. She's invincible.
- I like that your character-
(audience laughing)
I know, I know. I like this tease.
I'm very excited.
(Evangeline chuckling)
But I like the, invincible. Aw man.